I want to infiltrate oh I can't join bus
mind see it only took two minutes I need
to say that I want to infiltrate every
Academy members mind finally give your
desk oh my goodness because this is
astonished really well thank you very
much I appreciate that that's that's
awfully sweet okay thank you what did
Robert Mazur teach you about staying in
character we that's one thing that I
didn't need any lessons I'm you know I
mean what what he did for a living is
what I do for a living so slipping into
accepting embracing a character sticking
to it focused on that characters that
was the easy part what what wasn't easy
was then taking on the added layer of
pressure that that he lived with if I
don't do well I messed that up we need
to do that scene over again I'm sorry
added if he doesn't do well it could
cost him his life so when I go home I
could have a good day or a bad day and I
talked to my wife a mom I was little
rough we didn't quite you know connect
on that on that scene or we had some
disagreements and this didn't work I
would have but you know tomorrow is
another day looking he can't talk about
it when he goes up he has to keep
everything inside so that adds another
layer of pressure to him as a human
being holding on to that kind of tension
because he wasn't free to to say those
things and even if he had a good day or
something the transition to go from your
life is at risk you have to maintain
hyper focus you're only as strong as the
weakest link of your organization
informant could make a mistake and you
suffer for it to then transition and
going home and being a father and a
husband helping your daughter with a
math question or something that was
blowing my mind how did you do that how
did you become Bob Mazur after being Bob
masala all day long and taking on the
heirs of that guy that's and to me
that's what I thought audiences would
resonate with is that ok it's one thing
to have this this agenda this mission to
accomplish something good for society
it's his job but how does that man then
transition to being who he really is
especially do you think if he would not
have forgot that the CIA and superiors
and do this operation on his own he
would have succeeded no I think it takes
the the cooperation of an organization
that supports the protocols agenda that
was set forth as bureaucratic as it is
and everybody has a different timeline
and as it was they they were nervous
after two and a half years they were
deathly afraid of something cracking
something leaking and the whole thing is
gone done if they smell you know an
informant or something even if Bob
wasn't in physical danger if they sense
something was not right pack it up
change course and all your work is for
nothing that's at the least end of that
spectrum the worst end of the spectrum
is that could be destroyed and they
would kill you and as we bring out in
the movie they don't just want to kill
you they want to destroy everything
about you and
and so that that was a constant reminder
with Bob on a daily basis how much of
this era did you like how much did you
know of this era with the whole drug
tsunami almost in a he's coming to
Florida uh well very warehouse but I
don't do Drive never done cocaine or
anything like that so but it was all
round I went to an audition once we're
there was cocaine cocaine on the coffee
table and I walked into an office that's
like so there there's that right there
ok hit oven and a very good area like
that wasn't their date mm-hmm it was he
was it wasn't I mean that was uncommon
but they got sloppy they forgot you know
to put it away or whatever and there's
like oh we still have a you know
crazy but yeah I was very aware it was
it was a i think a manifestation of the
looseness of the 70s the 60s had the
sexual revolution and the awareness
right everything exploded the pill was
created don't trust Authority anti-war
anthems things like that and the
government is lying to us became a
reality in the 60s so then the 70
celebrated the the bacchanal that the
60s created we were like all over the
place indiscriminate sexual partners and
things like that which then transitioned
into the 80s and all of a sudden that
came to a halt because of AIDS because
of herpes and because of all these other
things but it was still the 80s the
people who are growing up an 80 still
wanted where's the me where's the mean
you know the 70s they got to do all
their wares to me so drugs man drugs
boom it was commonplace to see and on
the end of a night at a club a night
Club whether you know I even went to
studio 54 in the 80s it was a little
after its time but still studio 54 and
they said oh yeah we find little vials
of empty cocaine things all over the
place and just what was it was a wild
time and did you cos Escobar stories now
gets a lot of attention with narcos
Marcos obviously did you go and watch
that or did you I haven't seen it yet no
um and it wasn't something that was on
my list I heard great things about it
and I want to see it now but at the time
I wanted to stay focused on this story I
didn't want to be influenced by some
other story because I had I was up to my
eyeballs and doing research for this
story and talking to the real people and
Bob in the mirror and Kathy and all
these people and then just doing my own
research at the time and this particular
case and then developing the character
Bob maser and finding out where he lives
emotionally and how he became an actor
and put masks on him but first I had to
understand Bob Mazur can you talk about
the accountant was Bob is he cold hardly
talk Bob yeah no no he's not he's a very
friendly guy um he is careful though to
this day he won't be photographed or
videotape to her and his when he's on on
an audio what he's doing a radio or
something his voice is a little
augmented he put a lot of people in jail
get 85 arrests during that time and
most were convicted it's a it's a there
was a two-year preparation process after
the arrest two years to prepare for
trial the trials took two and a half
years so how I was tremendous amount of
the success rate of them going to prison
well a lot of those guys are now out of
prison and they didn't appreciate that
Bob turned out to be basically a liar he
wasn't who he said he was he did it for
the right reasons as far as his job and
for society but to them he was a liar
and and he was responsible for putting
them behind bars so there's a certain
amount of danger still swirling and and
as Bob's nature has it he will err on
the side of caution yeah what is his
motivation though I mean it's to do good
but that's a big sacrifice living a life
in fear is it just to do good or is it
well a lot of people are attracted to
the adrenaline rush of risk actors by
and large um professional athletes are
the kinds of people who let's take the
chance let's go for it i'm going to
hyper focus on my training and that's
worth it people who jump out of
airplanes people who goes swimming with
sharks people who you know who surf the
massive waves what what is it about
those people that make them do that and
there is there is a sense of
accomplishment there's a sense of a
fraction of the world can do what I do
there's some pride in that bob was good
at this and he was good at his job and
he was dedicated to his job when he
first started see chase this operation
it was on the smaller level and almost
like Russian dolls you don't oh there's
another one oh there's an oh there's
enough
it kept going it for him this kept
getting deeper and deeper and deeper so
does he say okay that's enough I don't
want to go any deeper no he say my god
they got all the way up to Pablo
Escobar's lawyer and maybe if given a
little more time they could have gotten
up to Pablo possibly maybe maybe not but
at any given time when you're widening
that net when you're accepting more and
more informants and more and more people
come in the more people the weaker your
organization is because chances are
you're only as strong as the weakest
member of a group and at any given point
it could have gone downhill quickly
that's so much about money around
nowadays dict about to talk about that
other operations do yeah uncover that
yeah and there's a book out called dark
money yeah that's really good and scary
at the same time governments are often
making decisions on the short term as we
have seen that come to haunt you in the
long term hopefully that sensibility is
changing and it's like let's not be
hasty but at times there are decisions
that need to be made to remedy the
immediate threat all we can do is try to
be safeguards and and watch it and
report it and hopefully your government
is behaving properly I knew I would
fault line itself
he's so cautious about everything
because it well number one I think it's
a it's a fantastic story yeah it his
operation brought down the seventh
largest bank in the world at the time
BCCI that's how big it was brought it
down it to a defunct level 85 arrests
initially and then afterward there were
up over a hundred total almost as many
convictions I mean it was a tremendously
successful issue and he couldn't tell
anybody we are human beings we need we
need to have a reciprocal situation we
breathe in breathe out we eat we
defecate sorry you know we are born we
live we die we everything is cyclical
and everything around us is cyclical if
you told a human being you can only
receive information but you can't speak
about it think of that think of what
that would do to the human psyche the a
human being saying you can I can tell
you how much I like you or appreciate
you your work is good you can't say a
word your you're at me I'm your mate
would say I love you and you know you
can't say a word I mean just think of so
I think he was bottled up I think he was
so filled with information that he had
to keep secret for so long that if he
did it in a way that gets it out flushes
it out of his system in a cathartic
nature that it would help him as a
person close that chapter and say that
was my life and now now he's a
grandfather and he's still married at
Evan everything's fine and he said got a
new life but I think I think it would be
hard for him to have that new life had
he not
an avenue to express himself how much of
the character did you develop before the
filming you met with Bob and then how
much did you kind of have different
epiphanies while on set or see his
mannerisms or there's the cheap well
there's there's all there's its
combination of everything with someone
like Bob who no one knows you have a
little more leeway in telling that non
fictional story with someone like Lyndon
Johnson I had to be much more accurate I
had to be much more on top of it before
stepping in front of the camera or on
stage with that but bob was more of I
certainly didn't intend to pattern my
behavior after who he was specifically
but there is if you ever were to meet
Bob which you probably won't but maybe
you will but you can he's around by the
way um he's a very meticulous guy he's
everything is orderly he is a check
double-check triple-check quadruple
check kind of guy when he was living in
tampa and actually operating out of
tampa on us on smaller scales in this
case with this he sent that guy to
prison and they said he actually goes
home he's actually has two children they
had a coat when they were driving around
when their kids are in the car and Bob
is constantly scanning in all the
mirrors and looking out constantly
looking if there was anyone that he saw
who he knew from any underground
operation or thinks that might be so and
so from another guy on average you would
mention a word a safe word said of it
and the kids would drop to the floor
and would be absolutely silent and still
and lay across the floorboards of the
car knowing this was the drill that's
what they live they went to his daughter
told me they said they went to zoo on
time and Bob thought he saw someone
ahead of them going through the entrance
who he thought was someone who was on a
current case turn around out they go so
that created a lot of tension within the
family is there wasn't a normal life and
it's difficult it was difficult for him
and he had a lot of a lot of stress and
tension and pressure due to you know
manage that he was down the bank and son
Earvin okay i was because i did this
point a real person change how you
approach a role versus playing a
fictional character yeah it does um you
know non fictional characters they're
men who did something of note that
people wrote about Dalton Trumbo they
played the Lyndon Johnson Bob Mazur
there are people who know him Bob Mazur
was very helpful to me in a case of
Dalton Trumbo LBJ I talked to the
daughters I talked to people who knew
him and you do you have an added
responsibility to present that character
as honestly as you can getting the
sensibility of that character with a
fictional character you can go anywhere
really you can create your own identity
because you are starting from scratch
it's interesting because some people
think that that would give you more
leeway well it can but it could also be
infinite whereas if you have the
parameters of a character
live you go well he lived during this
time period so you're not going to go
outside of that it's like here and that
kind of gives you some guideposts to say
okay what was going on in this time
period in the world and okay what oh
what was he married who is he married to
why was it you know so you can kind of
take what i call the funnel process of
when you start a character it's like
this massive opening that eventually has
to distill down to a performance you
can't keep it there because then it's
unwieldy it said that you're too many
characteristics it has to be has to make
sense and you have to shape it so that
when an audience finally sees that they
understand the whys they understand the
quirks of the characteristics that
you're presenting and some of that as to
your question is is not you're not
capable of finding that until you're on
the set give you an example we were
doing the you of all seen the movie yeah
we're doing the scene in the bathroom of
the anniversary segment and it was
scripted that he runs into more a senior
and he changes his attitude to be that
Bob musella and Eva's looking and like
what's going on but she knows enough
she's been around this guy enough to
just clam it and agree with whatever
he's saying so she's going along but you
can sense her nervousness and she sees
the gun and what's going on now I'm
thinking oh my god this is our
anniversary here comes this port waiter
with our anniversary cake well what
happened is that we didn't see the king
all of a sudden they bring this enormous
cake and I go that's the cake they go
yeah I go okay I have to say something
about this cake because it's because
people I would be the audience going
that's what you know so I I had to add
that okay we did it a couple times and I
get up and I parade the guy and bread
furman comes out to me he goes you know
you got it you gotta shove his death and
the fake the cake don't you think and I
go oh yeah when he said that it was his
idea when he said that it was like that
resonator yeah I've gotta do that so how
many cakes do we have they go 1 i'm
thinking who what prop you know it's
like come on you get one cake what if
that cake fell then your can't do the
cake seen it's like come on anyway
miscommunication happens so we have one
that we got to make sure we see so we
did it several times leading up to it to
the cake thing and then cut do it again
cotton we got it got now get the angles
or the two cameras no matter where we
are we're going to get this clear and we
told the waiter the young actor from
Britain is it what's he gonna do well I
hope you're okay with this but I'm going
to smash your head into the cake and he
goes cool and so we just came up with it
and did the thing it smashed is you know
and so that's something that you don't
you can't necessarily say ahead of time
you can it could be conceivable but you
have to be loose enough on the set to
allow the stimulus to allow the moment
the way someone's playing something to
expand the performance thank you we have
a great thank you thank you